derrière le dos du bois bonsoir
bienvenue à 24,60 pour cette lettre d'un
députés inquiets à un premier ministre
qui devrait l'intense dans le titre une
petite pointe d'ironie co2 de cynisme en
même temps que vous prenez pas au
sérieux peut-être l'épreuve du solo sur
ses politiques environnementales de
changement climatique mais le titre dit
déjà annonce les couleurs c'est à dire
que je ne sens pas françois legault
assez inquiets
je sens qu'il prend à la légère la
question des changements climatiques
je pense pas être le seul dans ma
génération avoir à avoir un premier
ministre qui s'est mis à parler un peu
plus quand même des changements
climatiques depuis les derniers mois je
pense qu'il a senti la pression
populaire mais on s'en portent que ça le
patient ne sens pas que ça vient le
chercher on sent pas que c'est une
réelle priorité pour lui et surtout un
problème c'est un problème parce qu'on
vit dans un système politique qui
concentre énormément de pouvoir entre
les mains du premier ministre
ça lui ça lui confère d'énormes
responsabilités et à l'heure d'une crise
écologique d'emploi civilisationnel on
s'entend hors satan ce que le chef
d'état du québec prennent ça au sérieux
et moi c'est parce que je sens quand je
le vois presque tous les jours à
l'assemblée nationale les québécois
l'ont élu à revenant à peine donc on
faisait confiance malgré les reproches
faits quand tu auras un plan vert qui
n'existait aucun existait pas il famille
troisième ligne 1 la pire gnl que dans
que dans le portrait par contre il y en
avoir d'autres élections
à ottawa on a quand même au québec a
choisi 35 députés face à face presque
avec le bloc je me suis pas dans les
annales parcourant presque entièrement
je vais vous trompez de premier ministre
vous siégez à québec mais je vous
trompez pas mais une excellente question
parce que j'aurais pu l'écrire au
premier ministre il serait peut être
plus vielles voilà ce que justin trudeau
sa vue différents
monsieur trudeau prétend que c'est une
priorité ouais mais il agit autrement
notamment en achetant un peuple un
monsieur legault prétends pas que c'est
une priorité et posent des gestes qui
vont dans le mauvais sens notamment avec
le troisième
avec le projet d'un portable à l'égard
de gnl québec mais oui je m'adresse à
françois legault parce que comme député
québécois c'est avec lui que je suis en
dialogue mais j'aurais pu aussi
interpellé juste mais vous touche à
quelque chose de fondamental me
semble-t-il que d'autres abordent aussi
mais vous êtes un élu et on parle
toujours de clientélisme politique vous
l'aborder dans cette question là est une
femme qui ressort de ce puits de ce
qu'on voit autour de nous l'achat de
plus en plus grand de voitures
énergivores madrid ou et de voitures
électriques en même temps ça grand
paradoxe pour poser les offres unis
c'est qu'on peut pas on peut pas la
faire avaler aux poêles en fonte dans le
fond de la gorge
7 cette urgence mais où cette transition
énergie de cycle si vous avez un prix
politique à payer est trop par où ça
passe pas puis voilà c'est un des
dilemmes auxquels je réfléchis dans
livres pied jeudi de suite je ne
prétends pas avoir toutes les solutions
mais je mets le doigt je pense sur un
dilemme réel qui est celui des hommes
politiques des femmes politiques à
l'heure de la crise écologique
notre logique électorale le clergé notre
logique dit le clientélisme électoral
faire en sorte que comme policier on a
beaucoup tendance à promettre plus de
confort aux électeurs pour aller
chercher leurs voix c'est comme ça quel
politicien conventionnelle faisait
campagne
le problème c'est que la crise
écologique nous force à réfléchir
différemment parce que là la crise
écologique sama des cécités aussi des
changements de mode de vie certains
sacrifices qui sont peut-être pas payant
électoralement et c'est la question que
je pose ma vie et ça fait pas comment la
classe politique va être à la hauteur de
ce défi là je pense qu'une des pistes de
réflexion intéressantes à dire il faut
que le discours de transition écologique
ça soit pas seulement un discours de
privation puis de renoncement il faut
aussi faire des politiques de transition
les politiques positives qui vont quand
qui vont constituer un gain de qualité
brin plus de temps avec les enfants
moins de temps dans la voiture des
commerces de proximité plus de
télétravail moins de distance entre le
lieu de travail et la maison ça c'est
des propositions qui peuvent séduire
tout le monde au québec et ça nous
permet de dire que la transition
écologique c'est pas juste des
sacrifices c'est aussi une meilleure
quelqu'un parce que vous qualifiez
monsieur legault d'environnementalistes
pragmatique et dont c'est comme ça
qu'ils se considèrent
vis de vous dire mais il faut justement
votre côté de grippe sont eux aussi plus
donc on fait pas ce qu'il faut pour les
investissements mais un exemple très
concret ces jours ci on ne connaît des
ratés canada qui diffuse des reportages
la détresse psychologique
on vend l'idée d'un formidable rem
transports collectifs mon à des milliers
de personnes qui sont en difficulté et
en détresse dans la banlieue nord de
montréal pour parler du sud aussi qu'ils
vont vivre si ce n'est pas on peut pas
dire que les voitures c'est à la casse
est un jour au lendemain non et c'est
pour ça que il ya un devoir de faire ces
choses-là démocratiquement le devoir de
les faire progressivement
mais disons une chose plus on attend
vous était juste plus belle car en avant
plus les gestes à poser vont devoir être
rapide et si on veut une transition qui
soit progressive
il faut commencer dès maintenant
malheureusement on actuellement
gouvernement québec qui se contente de
dire c'est pas si pire c'est pas trop
grave
calmez vous les jeunes le rang avec le
tout l'humour qu'on connaît à monsieur
legault il tourne un peu parfois en
dérision avec beaucoup de légèreté
le problème c'est que la science est là
et pas les jeunes a déclaré mardi qu'il
faut commencer à faire des gestes mais
en même temps dans l'es10 vante le
modèle québécois sur le carbone qui est
le lait les méthodes d'évaluation
environnementale gnl va passer par par
le bac mais en même temps on sait pas
trop à quoi s'attendre vous dénoncez la
décision de la fameuse cimenterie oui
pour deux décisions et koné mécano
décision qui va venir s'effondra
fonderie ont une angoisse by mail art
scénique là les gens veulent pas faire
de là il va pas faire qu'est ce que le
premier ministre voudrait matin que ce
que fait d'ailleurs sur la fonderie hier
soir bel exemple qu'il ya personne qui
demande de fermer la fonderie messier
pas dénigrer de du coin quand une des
petites québec solidaire le dit très
bien s'agit pas de fermer la fonderie
s'agit de demander à la fonderie de
respecter les mêmes normes
environnementales que celles qui sont
appliquées partout ailleurs au québec
avec cependant quelques années il faut
commencer par avoir des exigences
politiciens là on le connaît je commence
toujours par dire on veut pas déranger
l'entreprise avant même d'essayer de
voir ce qu'on peut faire et moi ce que
je dis c'est cette manière là de voir
l'économie où on dit tout aux
entreprises tout aux grandes entreprises
si on continue à faire ça je vois pas
moi comment va être capable de faire la
trace vous évoquez hulot en colloque à
démissionner
ferrandez lui qui est un peu plus
comment dire à ton autoritaire des six
décisive de steven guilbeault
on attend de voir c'est vrai parce que
vous le faites confiance à lui moi ce
que j'ai appris deux ans de zend de
politique c'est que les meilleures
intentions du monde ne valent pas grand
chose quand les orientations du premier
ministre ont priorité alors moi j'ai
aucune raison de douter de la kander qui
des bonnes intentions de seven
guilbeault mais son premier ministre et
celui qui a nationalisé un pipeline et
il ne fera pas autrement
c'est la même chose pour benoît charette
ici au québec il dénoue dit qu'il nous
prépare un plan tant mieux on a bien
hâte de le voir mais la vérité c'est que
dans notre système politique
les ministres ont le pouvoir que leur
premier ministre leur confère et c'est
tout et c'est pour ça que je m'adresse
au premier ministre gon dix ans comme
chef d'état du québec
vous avez une responsabilité morale et
historique de prendre en charge la
question du changement climatique sinon
vous allez peut-être donner vos
prochaines élections mais l'histoire va
vous retenir comme un premier ministre
échouer à ces responsables parce que
vous dites quand vous allez voir moi
j'aurais créé en 2005 en battant
l'allemand par 2050 moi je serais plus
assez sur le jeu à peu près l'année où
on va savoir la vacation on ne râle pas
échouer dans la lutte aux changements
climatiques et j'aurai en 2050
exactement large que françois legault
aujourd'hui et moi la main que je lui
tends se dit faut que la classe
politique là on soit à la hauteur de ce
défi là sinon on va avoir du mal à
regarder nos enfants dans nos yeux vous
savez bien les ports ne peuvent parler
de 80 dorion ce temps des voix qui dure
depuis une dizaine de jours je veux
faire goûter un court extrait de sa
présence à tout le monde en parle depuis
je commente les affaires qui fait pas
que la politique puis quand vraiment
politique c'est comme rentrer dans ton
petit carré de sable qui fait rien parce
que ce sont ces dommages en titre est
porté par un mouvement tu fais il ya des
gens qui croient en toi qui dis oui elle
est spéciale sas populeux tu as grâce à
un tarif tarifs puis le long
ton élection rentre dans ton tuteur et
ça laisse pas un fils de passer fait
comme les autres handball avec le
pouvoir que tu viens de gagner qui se
pose est servi aux citoyens qui viennent
de télé tu viens de le perdre en liberté
d'action tactique fut un militant tu es
plus capable de faire avancer les choses
si tu es obligé de gesté pagnolade dans
cet extrait de l'inde ou du bois mais
une critique féroce à l'endroit de tous
les députés de l'assemblée nationale qui
respecterait certain décorum qui
respecte les règles du jeu établies pour
les cadres n'ont pas établi de réflexion
ce qu'on peut commencer par faire une
réflexion
moi j'ai vu peut-être du mépris à
l'endroit des autres députés de
l'assemblée nationale qui rentrent dans
le karting
moi j'ai plutôt vu puis c'est je connais
bien quatrième je ne connais sa démarche
pays c'est une critique surtout du
système politique et médiatique qui tend
en effet à s'attendre à ce que les
politiciens soient tous parés et quand
il y en a une comme catherine qui
dérange qui bouscule pose des questions
pertinentes
c'est quoi être un homme politique c'est
quoi être une femme politique s'est pas
représenté les gens c'est des questions
fondamentales et catherine elle bouscule
ce système là et moi ce que j'ai entendu
dans cet extrait là c'est une critique
de cette volonté de conformisme et je
pense que c'est intéressant d'avoir
cette discussion mais en même temps
est-ce qu'on n'a pas avoir l'impression
parce que pour certains d'étape
formidablement subversive et
rafraîchissant absolument lé narcisse et
elle mène un combat pour avoir les
lumières le spotlight sur elle est
d'ailleurs certains ont 10% cathala tout
le monde en parle après avoir refusé les
entrevues de faire publier est-ce que
les manières de faire des débats
autrement tout aussi démocratiquement
que les moyens parce qu est ce que vous
risquez peut-être d'en payer le prix aux
partis politiques au québec solidaire le
pendant qu'on parle d'elle et ce combat
de décorum on parle pas de voter à séoul
on parle pas des sommes en jeu je pense
que la question doit surtout être posée
aux gens qui jeudi matin ont décidé de
faire pression sur le président pour que
catherine
rapport salon bleu je pense que c'est
ces gens là qui doit tomber et chira
leur sens des priorités voilà parce que
ce fait cette fameuse pièce de vêtement
katherine hull avait déjà porté alors si
par le passé ça avait pas fait de
problèmes et que ça on a fait cette fois
ci c'est que des gens qui ont décidé
politiser la question du décor avant
d'en faire un enjeu partisan que les
clubs à ce qu'il est parce qu ils ont de
la difficulté à tolérer quatrième à
l'assemblée nationale mais oui ayons le
débat et lyon la discussion sur comment
moderniser nos petits vestimentaire il
ya plein d'exemples plein parlement
notamment en ontario où le code est
beaucoup plus souple
je pense qu'on est rendu alors cet appel
clegg goutte faisant déborder le vase ou
la saturation et joie dans les rangs des
députés surtout des députés libéraux on
va se le dire qu'ils ont de la misère à
accepter qu'on puisse faire la politique
comme catherine la fée puis devraient
prendre leur mal en patience parce que
je pense pas que quatre dans l'intention
de rentrer gbagbo merci bien
nadeau-dubois j'appelle que vous étiez
sur le capot pour l'aide d'un députés
inquiets à un premier ministre de relais
vous auriez pu l'écrire 1 au premier
ministre si vous est peut-être que ce
sera la prochaine doivent apprendre à
l'autre qui a fait que monsieur lebon je
vais lui donner le monde dominateur
merci
[Musique]